[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns in
unserer kleinen sich aber auch nicht
heute soll es allerdings sich um diese
schildkröte geht meine lieben freunde
denn ihr seht ist bereits im titel
eingeblendet und wahrscheinlich könnte
es auch schon anhand des tempels
unschwer erkennen denn wir gehen heute
endlich in das brot sehr an monument ich
bin ein bisschen nervös und habe auch
ein bisschen schiss allerdings habt ihr
mir dafür eine menge tipps und in die
kommentare geschrieben wie zum beispiel
der hier den fand ich wirklich besonders
gut also daran versuche ich mich auf
jeden fall zu halten was mir auch
geschrieben wurde war das hier
darauf vertraue ich jetzt nicht so ganz
und dann wurde mir auch mega viel
motivierender krams einfach in die
kommentare geschrieben wie
beispielsweise das hier und ich sage
euch das gegenteil wird der fall sein
ich werde richtig rasieren bevor wir uns
allerdings in das ocr moment bewegen
werden müsse sich erst noch mal ja ich
habe die wasserflaschen vergessen immer
ganz kurz mit unseren glasflaschen
rechtsklick auf das wasser so dass wir
diese mit wasser befüllen
die sache ist dass wir uns erst mal
wirklich krass auf dieses monument
vorbereiten müssen das ist ein krasser
ort und deswegen müssen wir uns auch
dementsprechend darum sorgen und darum
kümmern dass wir dort nicht sterben
werden ich werde jetzt erstmal diese
drei wasserflaschen die reinpacken
lohnstopp hier einpacken und hier vorne
erst mal eine nette reinpacken so dass
wir hier und drei wasser
ich habe keine ahnung wie das dann heißt
aber das sind tränke und die können dann
weiter verzaubern und damit kann ich mir
tränke der nachtsicht erstmal machen
jetzt haben wir hier nämlich drei
seltsame tränke und jetzt nehmen wir
unsere goldbarren und machen diese
goldbarren um eine karotte rum so dass
wir dann eine goldene karotte bekommen
und wenn wir diese goldene karotte jetzt
hier anpacken sehen wir schon wenn wir
die netten rausnehmen und die goldene
karotte hier ein dass wir jetzt aus
diesen tränken nachtsicht tränke
bekommen
er fange ich jetzt wahrscheinlich nur
dafür braucht man nachsicht einerseits
dafür wenn wir nachher im ozean monument
sind dass wir halt unter wasser
vernünftig gut sehen können allerdings
benötigen wir die auch jetzt direkt denn
ich brauche einen kugelfisch
und diesen kugelfisch benötige ich auch
zum brauen dass ich mir nämlich einen
trank der unterwasser atmung machen kann
nicht auch und in die kommentare
geschrieben denn unter wasser kann ich
natürlich nicht atmen und ich bin
wirklich 10 15 minuten mindestens in
diesem moment drin deswegen wird uns auf
jeden fall ordentlich weiterhelfen ich
packe den redstone gerade hier rein
damit wir aus den tränken der nacht sich
die gerade nur drei minuten lange halten
das ganze so ein bisschen erweitern
können auf acht minuten das seht ihr
jetzt jeden moment dass das durch den
raps und quasi hier verlängern wird
diese drei kann ich mir auf jeden fall
raus nehmen wir haben den erfolgreichen
ii erzielt und ich werde jetzt auch
direkt einen dieser tränke trinken denn
ich benötige wie gesagt bereits wie
bereits gesagt einen kugelfisch und ich
zeige euch jetzt einfach mal den
unterschied also ich dir hier unter
wasser und schon ist es sieht so aus
wenn ich den jetzt allerdings trinke
sieht das alles so aus derzeit bilden
wenn ich direkt hier vorne google
verschwinden würde dann wird ziemlich im
verschwendung allerdings euch jetzt mal
ganz kurze time nützlicher dinge zurück
[Musik]
okay das ist auf jeden fall kugel für
stellt sich gerade aufgeblasen das heißt
einmal schlagen dann bekommen wir den
ich weiß ich habe jetzt gerade ein tier
getötet die sache ist allerdings dass er
diesen kugelfisch benötigen um uns einen
trank der unterwasser atmung zu machen
lassen das nach richters familie
[Musik]
ach du grüne neune ist eine party
okay wir machen ganz kurze höhlen action
hier ich will mal ganz kurz check war
das relativ tief ist auch hier
vielleicht irgendwo noch diamanten sein
könnten
ich habe halt 63 fall aber die sache ist
dass ich die alle benötigen werde
und nämlich auch und in die kommentare
geschrieben so dass ich da
ich
[Musik]
da sind zwei diamanten ich werde
allerdings direkt wieder hochgeht und
ich habe auch meine glück spitzhacke
nicht dabei also das kannst du doch
nicht aus dem wasser direkt diamanten
sind es sinnlos in meiner welt stehe
hier mal ganz kurz wieder weg wir müssen
uns nur merken dass das hier direkt
neben unserer kirche ist wo wir in der
letzten folge den gottesdienst
veranstaltet haben für die verstorbene
und das verstorbene scharf also hier
unten drin das sieht echt ziemlich ruhig
aus ehrlich gesagt na ja wir müssen uns
auf jeden fall merken ist dort diamanten
sind und das ist auch eine sache die ich
zu beginn jetzt erstmal noch ganz kurz
machen möchte und zwar muss ich ein paar
sachen auf mein schwarzes brett
schreiben wir nehmen nun also unsere
schilder und laufen hier zum schwarzen
brett und schreiben einmal hin die höhle
schreibt denn dahin bei kirche schreibe
ich einfach mal so dass wir da auf jeden
fall wissen dass wir die noch holen
müssen was ich auch noch hin schreiben
wollte war dass wir den kopf noch bauen
müssen dann haben wir immer noch hier
unten drin diesen villagers diesen
zombie village denen wir zurück erobern
müssen also dem wir irgendwie ich habe
etwas gelesen kommentar mit goldener
abfüllung dass man den daneben wie
zurückkriegt zu einem normalen winter
oder so und was sie alles drauf
schreiben wollte war dass wir einen
namen für unsere das passt jetzt nicht
so ganz herein wir brauchen einen namen
für unsere insel
ich sag immer zurück zur spornen sie
zurück zur heimat wir brauchen mal den
namen hierfür ich finde irgendwas
mexikanisches ganz geil irgendwie so
weiß ich nicht los flugrost oder
irgendwie so irgendwas mit lucio apropos
luca nirgends wird und da die sonne da
hinten schon wieder untergeht wochen
blutig was soll ich noch nicht habe
da die sonne da vorne untergeht blende
ich euch ganz schnell eine timeline wie
schlaf- und mich komplett vorbereitet
für das monument
[Musik]
so meine lieben freunde ihr seht schon
ein neuer tag erwartet uns hier in
unserer mannschaft welt ich werde direkt
runter gehen um mich zu meinem brötchen
bewegen so dass wir direkt jetzt rüber
fahren können zum hotel monument ich
habe mich gerade zwölf minuten lang
komplett auf diesem tag heute
vorbereitet und im inventar ich habe
einen kompass gemacht voronin den
kommentare geschrieben damit ich nachher
den weg zurück nach hause finden was mir
aufgeschrieben wurde weil du keine menge
blöcke mit nehmen damit ich mich dann
irgendwie wieder raus bauen kann oder
keine ahnung wofür genau aber ich
vertraue einfach mal dann sieht sie auch
schon ich hab mir akazienholz türen
gemacht das ist egal welche holzart das
ist hauptsache ich habe irgendwelche
türen mit dabei so dass sich die hin
platzieren kann und unter wasser atmen
kann
ich habe dennoch mir auch noch trank der
unter wasser atmen gemacht so dass sich
unter wasser die ganze zeit luft kriege
davon habe ich insgesamt drei stück
glaube ich mir gemacht also drei mal
acht minuten dementsprechend insgesamt
24 minuten und ich habe mir auch einen
trank der nachtsicht mitgenommen davon
habe ich mir sogar noch mehr gemacht das
heißt dem können wir sogar direkt jetzt
schon trinkt das macht allerdings
grenzen denn ich habe mir auch milch
einmal mitgenommen und davon muss ich
direkt einen trinken
sobald ich dort den unterwasser template
ozean monument erreicht habe denn das
wollen wir auch unten kommentare
geschrieben dass ich milch trinken kann
und dann sind die verzauberung quasi weg
also danke danke danke für eure
zahlreichen tipps soll die schau gerade
ob ich noch irgendwie vergessen habe
allerdings war es das auch glaube ich
bin extrem gut ausgerüstet ich habe auch
da sind die runden ich habe nur noch
einen level punktverlust nennen kann
also eine experience stufe
denn ich habe mein schwert seht ihr auch
schon komplett wieder sauber gemacht ich
habe es komplett repariert und ich habe
auch meine fast komplette rüstung also
hier fertig dann keine erfahrung mehr
habe ich auch repariert ich habe meine
glücks spitzhacke die diamant glück
spitzhacke hab ich leider nicht
repariert gekriegt weil ich dafür keine
erfahrung mehr hatte allerdings ist es
jetzt dann auch nicht weiter schlimm
wenn ich hier vorne gleich sterben
sollte hier sehen wir immer noch meine
kleine base die ich mir aufgebaut habe
ich werde diesmal jedoch mit dem boot
direkt rüber fahren mir die effekte
holen dann noch kurz zurück fahren dann
meine milch trinkt und dann sollte es
eigentlich los
die sind da freunde die teile wie sie in
mich an
steigt man aus dem boot aus ich werde
auch schon angegriffen ich weiß nicht
warum dieser effekt jetzt nicht zu mir
kommt eigentlich kriegt man ja hier
irgendeine abbau lähmung oder so das
passiert allerdings gerade nicht ich
werde mich dementsprechend jetzt erstmal
auf diese leute hier konzentrieren und
die töten
ich weiß nicht wie viel die aushalten
ich kriege auf jeden fall ordentlich
aufs maul gerade von denen wir vorne
noch trainer sagt jedem ein jahr richtig
viel schaden das hätte ich niemals
gedacht
ich stehe doch gerade weil ich keine
luft mehr kriege ich muss auf jeden fall
erstmal direkt den trend unter wasser
hartmut trinken ich dachte dass ich das
ding ins kriege dass sich diese
verzauberung von denen kriege dass ich
da nicht abbauen können aber irgendwie
passiert das gerade nicht ist das weil
ich dort schon mal war das macht ja auch
keinen sinn da können wir ja theoretisch
einfach wegfahren und dann klappt das
allerdings muss ich jetzt erst mal unter
wasser diese teile hier töten
das ist natürlich jetzt sind sport hier
unter wasser ok jetzt geht's los jetzt
habe ich die ablehnung bekommen das
heißt jetzt muss ich auch direkt schnell
meine milch einmal trinken so dass die
ablehnung weg ist allerdings jetzt
leider auch meine unter wasser atmen
deswegen werde ich mir mal ganz kurz den
trank der nacht sich die reihen ballern
und meine unter wasser atmen auch mal
eben ganz schnell so dass ich dann zwar
jetzt nur noch 16 minuten habe
allerdings ist das jetzt natürlich gut
gewesen dass es jetzt erst so spät kamen
hier der effekt indem er ganz kurz
schlagen ich muss mich wirklich darauf
konzentrieren dass ich dir erstmal töte
ich habe halt schärfe auf meinem schwert
ich weiß nicht wie viele haushalte okay
der eine ist tot
ich kann jetzt auch direkt zum nächsten
nicht muss mich jetzt einfach darauf
konzentriere ich muss es einfach darauf
schließen dass ich hier gerade ein
bisschen leben verliere
[Musik]
warum kriegt denn jetzt noch mal die
ablehnung
ich habe dir doch vorhin schon bekommen
und weg gemacht durch meine milch aber
ich werde mich jetzt allerdings wirklich
erstmal darauf konzentrieren diese
ganzen kleinen quallen hier zu töten so
dass die quasi erst mal wechseln und ich
dementsprechend freie bahn habe und dann
da reingehen kann die sache es
allerdings dass ich ja dann auch
trotzdem die milch trinken muss weil ich
da irgendwie rein kommen muss und ich
habe nur noch einen trank der unter
wasser atmen weil ich ja auch nur einen
kugelfisch gefunden habe
liga schon wieder abbau leben
ich trete hier die ganze zeit die teile
die spawnen alle neu und ich kriege die
ganze zeit eine neue abbau lebens ist
das normal oder ist meine welt wieder
irgendwie doof guckt euch mal an wie
viele von diesen teilen herumschwimmen
wie soll ich das denn schaffen hier
vorne sind zwar vorne es einer hier ist
noch einer
und hier vorne rum waren ja auch wieder
voll viele neue also ich hab euch ja gar
kein detail maps eingeblendet ich bin
losgefahren beim sonnenaufgang und die
sonne geht jetzt schon wieder unter das
ist ja unmöglich das zu schaffen die
hier alle zu töten beim eine unterwasser
atmung und meinen acht sich nach einer
minute gleich schon wieder weg sind
würde ich sagen fahre ich erst mal ganz
kurz weg von diesen dingen leider vorne
ist meine station ja gewesen ich bewege
mich jetzt erst mal weg von diesem teil
hier vorne und werde jetzt erstmal noch
mal kurz nach hause fahren wir ein paar
neue tränke machen
schlafen gehen und dann nochmal zurück
nach vorne hin fahren mit einer anderen
taktik
[Musik]
so die sonne da hinten geht unter ich
habe schon lange zeit nachdem kugelfisch
suchen müssen habe dann allerdings
schlussendlich leider eingefunden
die tauchen hier vorne sogar schon auf
ich finde jetzt mal ganz kurz den laden
und sammeln mal eben kurz die teams
einen die ich wohl nicht mitgenommen
habe und jetzt ist meine taktik dass ich
mich einfach direkt hier vorne
hinstellen war ich werde direkt wieder
angegriffen meine plan ist eigentlich
dass ich jetzt warte bis diese
verzauberung kommt ich mir dann direkt
einen milch einmal ein prügel
ich werde mich jetzt auch einfach hier
direkt reinbauen an der seite so dass
ich nicht von außen in rancho hat jetzt
werde ich hier direkt schon wieder
angegriffen es kannst du kannst ist die
nicht ausdenken
ich muss auch gleich auf jeden fall mir
direkt unter wasser atmen und alles rein
hauen ich hoffe allerdings dass jetzt
schnellstmöglich dieses ding kommt von
wegen abbau lähmungen der hamas schnell
den milch einmal rein und jetzt direkt
nachtsicht drauf und unterwasser art
wurde dass ich hier atmen kann ich weiß
nicht wo ich gerade abgeschlossen werden
wird liegen noch mal ganz kurz eben kurz
wieder weg so dass ich mir eben kurzem
brot essen kann und dann gehe ich direkt
acht monaten zombie sogar der erde
ankommen das hat das problem dass gerade
halt macht ist allerdings haben wir die
nachtsicht und auch die unterwasser
hatten also hier vorne jetzt ganz
schnell nein wir können uns dann auch
hier vorne einfach einbauen und hoffen
einfach mal dass die anderen teile nicht
hinter uns her kommen ich wäre jetzt
hinter mir auch direkt glocke setzen so
dass hier keiner mit reinkommt ich weiß
nicht ob die hier drinnen auf spawnen
allerdings sind wir jetzt im tempel drin
und wir können ab und vielleicht hätte
ich direkt zu beginn so vorgehen sollen
ich weiß jetzt gar nicht was sie
irgendwie unser ziel sein sollten wir
wohl in die kommentare geschrieben dass
man hier auf jeden fall schwämme
irgendwo kriegen kann in einem raum die
sind ja hier muss ich auch mitnehmen für
meine moderne strandhaus weder die sind
nämlich deutlich kleiner aus
die bloß down lampen also die hier auf
jeden fall auch mit ich hier auf jeden
fall komische geräusche was sie wollen
ich noch verarschen dass das so schnell
geht das macht doch gar keinen sinn ich
muss ganz ganz ganz ganz schnell in
diesen raum mit diesem schwimmen auf
jeden fall weil das ist das seltenste
was man hier kriegen kann bot hier vorne
ist der eingang glaube ich das schild
auf jeden fall auf welche von denen das
heißt ich gehe mal ganz fix ii wieder
hoch dass sich wenigstens ein bisschen
leiser machen ich nehme jetzt meinen
letzten milch aber ich weiß nicht ob
hier hinter vielleicht irgendwas ist das
sieht auf jeden fall so aus und jetzt
werde ich noch mal ganz kurz trank der
nachtsicht und trank der unter wasser
atmen machen ich habe jetzt vielleicht
eine halbe minute um mich hier noch ein
bisschen vor zu arbeiten sonst müssen
wir hier wirklich noch mal wieder hin
ich habe keine ahnung ob sich hinter
irgendwas befindet es sieht allerdings
danach aus wir haben der gold blöcke
ich dachte erst das wäre ein schwimmer
aber sind es sind einfach gold blogger
ich glaube es war noch niemals in
minecraft so traurig über einen gold
blog also die gold blöcke nehmen wir auf
jeden fall alle mal mit ich werde jetzt
auf die lampen hier auch erst mal drauf
scheißen ich werde jetzt noch mal ganz
kurz es nicht wo wir vorne noch lang
gehen können vielleicht hier hier war
mir nur nicht sagt ging und jetzt ist zu
spät
ich habe keine milch mehr das heißt wir
können uns wir können hier nichts mehr
abbauen
[Musik]
dann musst du dir ein stack milch
mitnehmen dann ist das ganze inventar
voll damit da ich allerdings noch die
unterwasser atmung und auch noch die
nachtsicht habe wie ich sagen dass wir
uns trotz sehen wir noch mal so ein
bisschen durchforsten und mal gucken was
man hier noch so finden kann hier vorne
haben wir die goldstücke mitgenommen und
ab
wie soll ich hier ich wollte ein
gekrabbelt von einem tier
deswegen hab ich grad zurück geschreckt
aber wie soll ich denn überhaupt gerade
rauskommt ist mir grad mal so
aufgefallen
wieso sind hier so viele von denen ich
hab ein bisschen schiss
die sind ja todes viele von denen wie
soll ich denn hier rauskommen ich habe
nicht mal milch aber ich kann ja nicht
mal mehr was abbauen gleich
wer sehr denn papa quelle was ist denn
los unter wasser das inventar der
verlauf der feier war riesig
walter was man das denn
sie war sein schwanz allerdings müssen
eingeblendet durch die wende durch alter
warum ist denn hier so eine riesen
quallen fisch unter wasser atmen wir
noch alles am start
ich habe noch drei minuten abnehmen da
muss ich mich direkt in wir ausbauen und
herstellern wie riesig der ist gott
aber den weg vor mir
aber der wird wahrscheinlich auch ein
bisschen mehr schaden machen als die
anderen
ich würde mich trotzdem jetzt erstmal
auf diese kleinen konzentrieren und
jetzt mal hier auf den gruppo mein gott
ich habe eine große diamant rüstung
kommt nennt verzaubert und er hat mich
schon mal der hälfte guck mal ich habe
explosionsschutz 1342 diamant rüstung
und diamant schweren der typ bach nicht
so viel schaden
qualle alter da müssen
das kriegen wir mit dem töten oder
wieviel leben hat er denn und jetzt auch
noch die kleine von der seite
durch die krise
doch nicht ausdenken
versteckte sich hier noch hinter der
seite
sterben okay ist tot was hat er geglaubt
ich habe keine ahnung was das jetzt wahr
wir schauen uns das an wir haben das ein
schwamm er hat gesperrten schwamm saugt
lassen
das ist unfassbar wichtig wer mit dem
schwamm damit an unseren unterwasser
tunnel bauen wir haben nur noch eine
minute 50 ablehnung das heißt danach
werden wir uns direkt die wieder an die
oberfläche bewegen ich werde noch
versuchen so ein paar lampen mitzunehmen
keine ahnung was das hier ist oder hier
vorne das scheint mir hier die mitte von
dem ganzen dingen zu sein so hoch wie
das hier geht ich schwimme hier drunter
her lang hier ist nichts mehr noch mal
kurz hier drunter her langen schwimmen
hier sind nur noch die anderen kleinen
mit denen können wir jetzt die sie
aufnehmen
hier fordert es noch mal so einen raum
das heißt hier werden sich
wahrscheinlich noch ein paar gold blöcke
drin befinden
die sache ist allerdings und da hatten
wir schon die goldberger wahrscheinlich
gab es nur einen goldtraum die sache ist
allerdings dass ich gleich direkt
aufpassen muss ja noch eine minute 10
die apollon danach muss ich direkt weg
nach hause und die ganzen sachen
sicherlich auch schon auf 15 level
also wenn man wirkliche palette haben
will dann ist das ihr auf jeden fall der
richtige ort hier ist ein kugelfisch
auch noch gewesen gott alter jetzt kommt
ihr aber auch alles zusammen
ich krieg' ich habe 95 minuten abbekommt
das heißt wir haben noch eine
möglichkeit hier raus zu kommen und das
ist über den haupteingang wo gott wo war
er denn noch mal ich glaube der war hier
hinten um die ecke rum nämlich nicht
aber irgendwo hier in der ecke war der
auf jeden fall
ich glaube wenn ich ja genau hier hoch
schwimmen und dann hier vorne nochmal
hoch warte ich töte erstmal ihnen hier
vorne sagt ich hier vorne auch noch mal
eben schnell weg
es ist sehr sehr langwierig die ganze
karte hier aber jetzt gehen wir hier um
die ecke rum und dann müsst ihr links
der ausgang sein und genau jetzt noch
hier unter den hier tödlich noch mal
eben einmal schnell und dann haben wir
wenn wir jetzt hier vorne wartet kurz
wir müssen jetzt ihr lang
und dann war das nämlich genau dann
müssen wir hier vorne war das hier vorne
war der hauptausgang hier sollten wir
auf jeden fall hinkriegen ich habe angst
dass meine wenn nur noch zwei minuten
nachtsicht und dinge ist dass wir hier
irgendwie vernünftig rauskommen
allerdings müssen wir jetzt einmal kurz
hier vorne lang und jetzt hier links ist
der hauptausgang und jetzt einfach
direkt hoch und weg ich werde jetzt
keinen mehr angreifen die werden mich
allerdings wahrscheinlich noch angreifen
ich werde jetzt mit ganz ganz fix mal
ein brötchen schnappen wo ist es denn
bobbys dann abgestellt
hier vorne ist mein brot hier steht und
jetzt werden wir uns direkt hier fiesel
ich habe einen schwamm wahrscheinlich
oder ich glaube zumindest dass das auch
stimmt
das wird noch in die kommentare
geschrieben gibt es hier noch einen
riesig größeren raum mit noch mehr
schwimmen am start so dass wir uns dann
dort noch mal hin bewegen können und
noch mehr schwimmen kann allerdings
haben wir zumindest erstmal einen
schwamm und der wird erst mal ein
bisschen ausreichen
und damit meine lieben freunde sind
jetzt auch schon am ende der heutigen
episode angelangt es ist wunderschön das
passt perfekt die sonne geht gerade
perfekt auf wir befinden uns in unserem
bildchen wir haben den schwamm wir haben
eine menge gold blöcke bekommen wir
haben chris marin kristalle bekommen und
das ist wirklich sehr sehr nice denn die
können wir für unseren acquisa tor
verwenden so dass wir damit an unter
wasser bauen können und den schwamm
benutzt wir dann auch für die
unterwasser situation mit dem tunnel ich
weiß dass es in version 1.17 hinzugefügt
wurde
dass man jetzt auch unter wasser
schienen legen kann
ich möchte allerdings unbedingt an
unserem glastunnel festhalten und das
wird auf jeden fall auch noch ein ziel
sein was mit dem nissan gehen müssen von
daher park jetzt mal ganz kurz unser
brötchen hier vorne sprinten eben noch
mal schnell rüber zu unserer kisten
krippe so dass ich mir dort ein schild
rausnehmen kann denn das muss ich mir
auch direkt auf jeden fall auf mein
schwarzes brett schreiben dass ich das
nicht schon wieder vergessen
genauso wie mit der diamant höhle
beispielsweise einmal hier das
schildchen nehmen nun schnell hier zu
unserem schwarzen brett rüber und
schreibe ich da direkt daran dass wir ja
den und her was der tunnel noch fertig
stellen müssen allerdings meine lieben
freunde will ich an der stelle das
heutige video jetzt auch beenden
das hier sind die sachen die ich
bekommen habe neuen press marin scherben
acht chris martin siegel ein prisma rhin
vier mal dunkler prisma die nacht gold
blöcke und 25 bis marin kristalle damit
können wir uns dann richtig schöne
lampen bauen die wir für unsere
strandhaus villa dorthin benutzen können
damit gerade claas daun
ich freue mich auf jeden fall total den
schwamm den kann man dann einfach in den
ofen packen und dann haben wir einen
trockenen schwamm und wenn wir dann im
wasser platzieren dann ist das ganze
wasser im umkreis weg ich werde jetzt
aber ganz kurz die items hier nämlich
die tür zugemacht
entschuldigung ich werde ganz kurz aber
die items sortieren das werde ich jetzt
allerdings nicht aufnehmen
[Musik]
ich hätte nicht ja ich packe die items
in die kisten
ich habe noch nie getötet irgendwann
meine lieben freunde gebe ich euch den
zieht und dann können alle leute die
sagen dass ich irgendwas platziert habe
oder titel können sich dann direkt davon
überzeugen lassen
daumen hoch unter video da wohl nicht
meinen kanaldeckel auf die glocke wenn
ich das nächste video über morgen um 20
uhr nicht verpassen wollten schreibt mir
jetzt und in die kommentare was ich da
machen sollten das könnt ihr immer
wieder entscheiden
[Musik]